[Musique]
en 1972 Enrique essenger accompagne le
président américain Richard Nixon en
Chine un voyage historique qui change le
monde
la discussion d'un excès de visiter Mao
à bouleversé la politique internationale
à ce moment la Chine disait au
soviétique nous sommes indépendants nous
allons mener nos affaires extérieures
comme il faut cette visite surprend la
planète parce qu'elle survient en pleine
guerre froide les États-Unis avaient
rompu toute relation avec la Chine
depuis la victoire des communistes en
1949 le rapprochement avec Pékin vise à
éviter un affrontement fatal entre
puissance nucléaire c'est Enrique
de ce changement très très important la
visite en Chine propulse un nuit
kessenger à l'avant-scène il sera au
coeur des bras de fer entre puissance
pendant 50 ans il rencontre lui-même au
titoung qui lui parle de Taïwan
le président chinois dit au secrétaire
d'État on peut attendre 100 ans mais on
va reprendre Taïwan un jour dans une
longue entrevue au magazine dit quand le
Myst et lui que c'est aujourd'hui
centenaire s'inquiétant encore des
tensions entre son pays et la Chine
même 50 ans après avoir quitté le
département d'État en lui cassenger
demeure un homme de pouvoir consulté par
des chefs d'État de partout dans le
monde il a parlé avec les gens les plus
puissants au monde il a connu la plupart
des chefs des grands pays mondiaux il a
connu tous les chefs de la Chine il a
connu et conseiller tous les présidents
américains depuis John F Kennedy et tous
les présidents soviétiques et russes y
compris Vladimir Poutine il dénonce
l'invasion de l'Ukraine
dit-il ne doit pas céder un pouce du
territoire qu'elle contrôlait avant la
guerre
ce serait dangereux pour le temps et
pour nos enjeux en Asie l'Ukraine
inquiète le diplomate mais il juge que
la nouvelle proximité entre Moscou et
Pékin ne sera pas durable
[Applaudissements]
de la politique étrangère des États-Unis
l'ancien secrétaire d'État a appuyé des
opérations spéciales visant à renverser
des gouvernements comme celui de
Salvador Allende au Chili qui sera
remplacé par la dictature meurtrière
d'Augusto Pinochet ici ce fil en gloire
Radio-Canada Montréal